Israeli air strikes have hit two
Villages across the border in southern
Lebanon plumes of smoke were seen rising
in nura on the Mediterranean Coast a
drone strike is also reported to have
hit kurella in the East it's the latest
in nearly three months of crossborder
attacks between the Israeli Army and
Hezbollah at least 179 people have been
killed on both sides since October the
7th including 23 Lebanese civilians Ali
Hashim is in nura where there are fears
there may be an escalation
in fact yeah the first day in the year
several air strikes the uh Hills behind
me I think you you can see them on uh
the screen right now there were around
eight Israeli strikes warplane strikes
huge massive floes of smoke in this area
also a couple of uh missiles from drones
in this same area so around 10 attacks
in uh the hills surrounding nakura where
we are also to towards the east in
karilla uh around three air strikes
marun Ras also in the central sector
three Israeli attacks by with artillery
and also drones also I'm just receiving
alerts right now of isra allets from on
the Israeli side of uh a drone
infiltration from the Lebanese side now
during the day there were there were
several attacks uh an attack preceded
the Israeli uh airplane War strike the
war plane uh strikes here in uh near
nakura there were several explosions
here from the other side of the Border
also heah claimed responsibility for one
attack on um an Israeli military
position called hadban however there are
also reports of uh a missile that was
launched towards the Mah settlement but
this went without any claim of
responsibility so a lot of is happening
just like yesterday but today the the
the the air strikes were massive and it
seems especially after hasah deputy
secretary General's speech yesterday
everything is being set for a new round
of
escalation I'm joined on by luchano
zakara he's the associate professor of
Gulf politics at Qatar University we
just heard Ali Hashim there talking
about the the the issues of Northern
Israel and Southern Lebanon Israel
Hezbollah
there's a real worry isn't there about
the escalation of the conflict in Gaza
transpiring and becoming more evident in
the region and that's worrying its
neighbors of course it's it's woring uh
we have been pending on on declarations
from in uh from uh hisbah leaders Anda
at the beginning of the conflict with
the expectation that this idea of AIS of
uh resistance that was expanding in
order to contain Israel or to retaliate
against Israel would make a Lebanon to
enter into direct confrontation with
Israel this did not happen however this
low uh low level low intensity
confrontation has been ongoing the
problem is uh if this kind of uh U
limited actions can become much bigger
because of a miscalculation of what can
actions can be taken or what kind of
deterrence operations can be taken in
both sides a miscalculation on any side
can derail any kind of containment from
both sides and drive to a more direct
confrontation indeed I mean it's not
just miscalculations is it it's really
statements that are also made that be or
can be seen as being quite inflammatory
it's only a few days ago I think it was
the Israeli Prime Minister saying you
know we'll we'll hit Iran directly if we
need to I mean those sorts of very
verbal overt threats we aren't just
going to worry Regional neighbors
they're going to worry Europe they're
going to worry the US and and and Iran
has already now as we've seen in the
last 24 hours sent a warship into the
Red Sea since the very beginning there
was also this battle of narratives about
who is shouting louder uh who is more
ready to engage in a war I mean we have
been listening this is the very
beginning Israel is ready to retaliate
to any anybody who attacks them the
other day they mentioned the seven
different fronts from where uh Israel is
being attacked and that they said that
they will retaliate to all of them if
they all of them attack them Iran has
been saying exactly the same so of
course we're in a in a situation in
which everybody is threatening to
retaliate or to attack directly to
engage directly in the war but so far
this is not happening because nobody
really wants nobody really is interested
in expanding that the the conflict is
already expanded because other uh areas
are are being engaged in in in the war
mean with the Red Sea with Southern
Lebanon with some incidents in Syria and
Iraq h of course this is creating more
problem and anything again can derail
any uh short-term expect expectations in
terms of focusing only the conflict in
in gasa and expand to the the whole
region nobody wants that but difficult
it is happening the Israeli Prime
Minister the war cabinet the military
can can feel emboldened that they have
the upper hand so they think they have
that because they have the US's support
backing them up and we've seen that in
the way Munitions have now been
transferred bypassing Congress uh as has
uh the President Joe Biden but Joe Biden
is heading into his own election in
2024 and one wonders where the line will
be where he has to really focus on his
own reelection and Israel and its issues
with Gaza with Hamas not so much take a
sideline but take second place because
his campaigning to win that election is
going to be at the Forefront do you
think there is going to be that sort of
problematic decision to be made by him
and the Democrats it is already a
problematic decision there are a lot of
Voters from the Democrat Party that they
are considering what Biden is doing and
they are criticizing him and that's why
he had to take this measure of sending
military aid in emergency because he
knows that his own party would not be
willing to to support that in the in the
in in the Congress the problem is when
Biden will calculate about how many
votes he will lose on one side and how
many votes would win we have to bear in
mind that the rep Republican voters are
much more pro-israeli than the the the
Republicans are much more Pro Israeli
than the Democrats so Trump on the other
side which is probably the the the
candidate will not have a pro
Palestinian position so the point is how
Biden will make this calculation about
how many votes he can win from the
Republican side if he keeps supporting
Israel as the way they did until now
we'll see what happens and of course we
get more insight from you as evening
progresses Lan zakara thank you thank